clark county school students well  they're going to be staying at home last  night board members postponed a vote  on allowing children to transition back  into campus learning  trustees debated the administration's  hybrid proposal for hours last night  if approved students would have returned  in january to campus  while some staff would go back to work  in december trustees cited a  spike in coronavirus cases in nevada and  they just say there's too much  uncertainty to make a decision  there is more work to be done and if  this  board's inability to make a decision has  now hampered that  we are hurting our children even more we  need to have  a plan where people are volunteering to  go in without worrying about  losing their lives trustees did not set  a future date for a vote on this measure  so it's unclear when the hybrid plan  will come up for discussion once again